okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p this
is kind of funny back in 2011 we did a
story about a Christian child pastor
well though he's not a child he pastors
children named Damon Thompson who
effectively outed gay congregants by
telling them if you're gay come up to
the stage this was eight years ago that
I covered it there is a Christian woman
who's upset with me about that story who
called in yesterday take a listen to
this hi my name is Lauren Connor I'm
calling in regards to your exclusive
pastor Damon Thompson anti-gay preaching
outing exposed not really sure what you
think you exposed but he is a godly man
and I would like to come on your show
right in honor of Diamond Thompson
I'd like to come on their phone and
speak since you're letting all these
idiots come on and speak untruthful
things so you can come attack me I'm
Facebook looking up more in Conor I'll
be looking for you yes we're gonna pass
on that that story is eight years old
and fortunately a lot of these sort of
anti-gay preachers have people have lost
interest in them as the law has
continued to move forward in the right
way when it comes to the issue of gay
rights so at this point Lauren were not
interested in following up on that story
but clearly hitting a nerve story that
seems to have deeply affected this woman
and I appreciate her calling but we've
moved beyond the story so we won't be
having her on we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today become a
member or a patron ww join pakman.com or
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get instant access to the bonus show